المترجم: Nawal Sharabati
المدقّق: Nada Qanbar
اسمحوا لي أن أقول لكم معلومة جديدة
لا يعرفها الكثير من الحاضرين
هل تعرفون أن الثلج لو تكّون تحت ضغطٍ عالٍ،
يصبحُ أقوى من الإسمنت؟
ويعني ذلك أننا نوفرُ أموالًا طائلة لصرفها
على المرافق المائية دون حاجة لذلك.
في الواقع، أنا من المهتمين بشؤون البيئة.
ففي إحدى المرات،
كنتُ أقرأ عن كوارث انهيار السدود
وكيف يحدثُ انهيارها،
ومن ضمنها انهيار السد العالي
ففوجئت من قراءة أنه في حالة انهياره،
سترتفعُ المياه في الشوارع إلى خمسة أمتار،
أي ما يعادلُ ارتفاع مبنى صغير
أو حاوية شحن.
وفي إحدى المرات،
كنتُ أتناول زجاجة ماء من الثلاجة
فوجدتُ طبقة جليد على فوهة الزجاجة
التي منعت انسياب المياه من الزجاجة.
فتبادر إلى ذهني السؤال: لماذا لا نستخدم
المنشآت الجليدية لحل مشكلة انهيار السدود؟
دعونا في البداية أن نرى أهمية تفكيرنا
بشيء من هذا القبيل.
تنقسم مشاكل السدود إلى ثلاثة اتجاهات:
أولًا: مشاكل بيئية،
ثانيًا: مشاكل صحية،
ثالثًا: كوارث إنسانية.
بالنسبة إلى المشاكل البيئية:
تمنع هجرة الحيوانات أو الكائنات البحرية
من مكانٍ إلى مكان.
كما أن الحديد والإسمنت ملوث بالماء،
وفي حالة جفاف المجرى المائي
يكون منظر السد ملّوث للعين بسبب عدم أهميته
بالنسبة إلى المشاكل الصحية:
يجعلُ اختلاط المياه بالصرف الصحي
المياه ملوثة وغير صالحة للاستهلاك البشري
حيث أن المياه تنظفُ نفسها بنفسها
في حالة الانسياب
وتحرمُ المياه من هذه الخاصية
في حالة وجود السدود.
وبالنسبة إلى الكوارث الإنسانية:
إن وجود المياه في ظل محطات الكهرباء
أو أبراج الكهرباء
يعملُ إلى إحداث الصواعق،
ويعرضُ الأشخاص إلى الغرق
وذلك نظرًا إلى ارتفاع منسوب المياه،
إضافة إلى موت الحيوانات، وتلف المزروعات
نحتاجُ في حالة الكوارث الإنسانية
إلى التدخل الخارجي لإنقاذ المناطق المنكوبة
ويكون عادةً التدخل إمّا محليًا أو دوليًا.
وتحتاجُ عملية الإنقاذ هذه إلى دعمٍ لوجستي.
ويتضمن الدعم اللوجستي في هذه الحالة
مشاكل مثل الطرق والميناء
والحافلات التي تنقل مواد الإغاثة
التي تنجمُ عنها مشاكل في ظروفنا الحالية.
بالإضافة إلى التكلفة التي قد ننفقها
على بناء السدود والموانع المائية.
وفي ظل الأزمة الاقتصادية الحالية،
لن تستطع دول كثيرة تحمل هذه النفقات.
وبإمكانكم تخيل المشكلة واستمرارها في ظل
تأخر النجدة التي نراها يوميًا في حياتنا.
يأتي هنا دور المنشأة المائية
في حل كل المشاكل التي ذكرناها
وموضوع الحل هو باختصار عبارة
عن شرائح مكونة من سبيكة،
والسبيكة مكونة من خليط من المعادن
له مواصفات خاصة:
تتحمل البرودة الشديدة ولها مقدرة عالية
على التبادل الحراري مع الوسط المحيط بها
يشبه شكل هذه الشرائح نفس الشرائح
التي توجد خلف الثلاجة تمامًا
إلا أن حجمها أكبر، ومتصلة بمصانع أو غرف
التثليج ومثبتة على ضفتي المجرى المائي.
عند الفيضان أو الحاجة، تتحرك هذه الشرائح،
وتشتبك بعضها ببعض لتعترض المجرى المائي
وتبدأ مصانع التبريد أو غرف التثليج
بضخ بلورات الثلج على الشرائح
بالإضافة إلى سائل التثليج الذي يمر
من خلال هذه الشرائح
سائل التثليج مثل سائل النيتروجين
الذي حرارته 180 درجة مئوية تحت الصفر
تبدأ هذه الشرائح بعمل تثليج للمياه
المُلاصقة بها
فتشكل لنا سد له نفس شكل
ووظيفة السد العادي.
وبذلك نكون قد منعنا تدفق المياه وانسيابها
ومنعنا حدوث الكوارث التي ذكرناها سابقًا.
وذلك دون استخدام مواد من الخارج،
لأن كل المواد المستخدمة من الموقع نفسه.
بمعنى أننا استخدمنا مياه الفيضان
لحل مشكلة الفيضان بحد ذاته.
هل يقفُ موضوع الحل هنا،
أو هل له تطبيقات أخرى؟
يشبه هذا الموضوع الصلصال الذي أقوم بصنعه
وأضعه في عدة قوالب بأشكال ووظائف عديدة.
حيث يمكنني تكوين الشرائح على شكل ميناء
لترسو عليها السفن لتفريغ حمولتها.
أو على سبيل المثال، في حالة البراكين
عندما تتعطل الخطوط الملاحية الجوية،
وتضطرُ الطائرات للهبوط في أماكن معينة
في حالة حدوث البراكين
في هذه الحالة، يمكننا عمل مطارات جليدية
لهبوط الطائرات لتقديم مساعدات
وإنقاذ الركاب أو أي شيء كان.
حصل هذا الموضوع على براءة اختراع عالمية،
لكن لم يتم تنفيذه حتى الآن.
يحتاجُ لتنفيذه فريق بحث أو عمل
مكّون من مهندسين مدنيين لعمل التصميمات
ومهندسين مكانيكيين لتحسين حركة الشرائح
ومهندسي مُستلزمات لتزويدنا بما هو جديد
لصنع السبائك ومواد التثليج
ويحتاجُ إلى دعمٍ لوجستي من توفير أماكن
للمختبرات وصنع نماذج بدائية،
واستخراج التصاريح اللازمة
مِنْ الجهات المعنية.
في الواقع، يمكنُ لهذا الموضوع أن يوفر
للدولة أمورًا عديدة مثل:
إنقاذ حياة البشر عند الكوارث،
وتوفير الأموال الطائلة في حالة الإنقاذ.
بالإضافة إلى تنشيط مجال السياحة،
وفتح آفاق كثيرة في مجال البحث العلمي.
ليس بالضرورة أن تحتاج أصعب المشاكل
لحلول صعبة أو معقدة.
يمكنُ لأبسط الأمور مثل زجاجة ماء
أن تكون حلًا لأصعب المشاكل.
شكرًا لكم!
(تصفيق)